[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEORGIOS MOSCHIDIS: The subject that I'm in?
General relativity.
I first met my adviser,
Mihalis, in Greece.
And while I was an undergraduate student,
he came to give a talk at the University that
I was in.
MIHALIS DAFERMOS: Several professors from
the National Technical University came up
to me and said, you know, there was a student
who was sitting in your talk.
You should really take that student to Princeton.
GEORGIOS MOSCHIDIS: It was the first talk
about mathematical general relativity that
I went to in my life.
And I was really fascinated about the subject.
MIHALIS DAFERMOS: It didn't take long for
me to be convinced that we should certainly
accept him at Princeton.
And the difficulty would be competing for
him to come to Princeton.
GEORGIOS MOSCHIDIS: Exactly, because I want
to do general relativity, Princeton was the
best place for this subject.
These are called Einstein's equations.
These are the equations that Einstein wrote
down, in 1915, in his paper about general
relativity.
On the left hand side, these are terms which
somehow describe the geometry of space.
These are terms which describe gravity, if
you want.
And on the right hand side, you have terms
which come from the matter.
This is the energy, in terms of
matter at a certain point.
So this equation actually tells us how the
presence of matter, at some point in the universe,
determines the gravity around this point.
MIHALIS DAFERMOS: Mathematics is a very rigid
subject.
You have to prove theorems.
As much as you want to prove the theorem,
if the theorem doesn't want to be proved,
you're not going to prove it.
And some theorems are very, very difficult.
Some problems are easy to state but they spent
hundreds of years, maybe more, in the category
of unsolved.
Georgios solved that problem.
He showed that a sort of arbitrarily small wiggle
in the dust is sufficient, eventually, to
create a black hole.
GEORGIOS MOSCHIDIS: Even the presence of moments
when you think you've solved something, but
then turns out that this was wrong, these,
psychologically, they are also important,
because they motivate you to dig deeper into
the problem.
So, this is also counted as progress.
[MUSIC PLAYING]